معنى الالم انقره النائب السابق عن حزب
العداله والتنميه ياسين اقطاي اهلا بك سيد
ياسين اولا نعزيكم بهذا المصاب الجلل
والضحايا جراء هذا الزلزال الذي وقع في
الجنوب التركي وشمال السوري لكن كيف تقيم
السلطات في تركيا
هذا الزلزال ما مدى خطوره توابعه وكيف
تتعامل معه الدوله التركيه برايه
اشكركم على هذا التعزيه هذه هي جدا يوم
احزن بالنسبه لتركيا وبالنسبه للعالم
الاسلام كله يعني لان تركيا الان الحمد
لله هي من ما كانت تقدم مساعدات انسانيه
للعالم لكل العالم الذي كان يحتاجها
وتحتضمن من اللاجئين ومن كانت دائما
مؤسساتها للكوارث دائما تلحق وهي لاحقه في
في
باكستان وفي الصومال وفي
سوريا في كل اماكن وتركي طبعا
هذه المؤسسات التركيه في المؤسسات وثقافه
التركي
للدعم الانساني صار لها تجربه كبيره
وتجربه متراكمه وبهذه الناحيه طبعا ولكن
في تركيا ايضا لها تجربه كبيره في تركيا
من الناحيه الزلزال ومن السيول ومن الحراق
ومؤسسات تركيا من اجل هذه تلك الكوارث
قدرات كثير كبيره الحمد لله لتوفير
المساعدات وتوفير الاطفاء النار او انقاذ
الارواح من من
الخراب ولكن طبعا لا شك هذه هذا هو
هذا الزلزال هو شيء غير مسبوق يعني منذ
100 سنه من عهد تاسيس جمهوريه التركيه لم
لم نشهد مثل هذا
قادره على التعامل معه لكن كما تقول سيد
ياسين بانه غير مسبوق منذ 100 عام ما هو
حجم الضرر ما هو حجم الضرر وبالتالي
التحديات التي تقف امام الان
شخصيته امام الدوله التركيه جراءه اكيد
اكيد مازال الان حجم الضرر الان الشيء غير
محسوب يعني هو في الحساب سيحسب في طبعا
ولكن هذا لا يقارن مع الزلزال الاكبر الذي
حصل في 1999 17 اوغست الذي كان حصل في
مرمره وكان في ايام الصيف يعني كان له
ايجاء كان ما كان ايجابيات طبعا كان له
جانب سهل يعني من ناحيه
للاجابه عنهم ولكن هذا مع كل مع كل حجمه
الذي يعني اتسع الى عائشه اكثر من عشره
مدن تركيا الكبرى
في جنوب تركيا
ولكن هذه في طبعا اضيف عليها لا ننسى
سوريا شمال سوريا ايضا هي
للاسف هي تعاني من هذا الزلزال
مع ذلك طبعا
الشتاء البرد
والمستوى الادنى في الحراره
تعطي اكثر صعوبه في الاتجاه وفي تلبيه
المساعدات
وهذا صعب طبعا لمن لمن يتلقى
يتضرر من هذا من هذا الزلزال ولكن تركيا
مع كل مؤسساتها ومع كل حكومتها انت التعرض
لها قدرات التنسيق للمساعدات
وللاستجابه ايضا طبعا للاستجابه
والاسترحاب كل من المساعدات من الخارج
ايضا طبعا يرحب بهذا
الكارتات الانسانيه تسبق قضيه انسانيه
اكثر مما هي شيء وطنيه وشيء قوميه او شيء
محدوده لان هذه قضيه انسانيه وطبعا تركيا
اعلنت بان ترحب كل
كل الاقتراحات المساعدات من الخارج
شيء مرحب
ونشكر على كل من من يريد ان يقدم هذا تلك
المساعدات ومع ذلك طبعا انت تروا كل
الوزراء في الساحه وكل كل القدرات التركيه
للانقاذ
وللمساعدات كل الان في الساحه مع مجتمع
المدني التركي ما شاء الله مجتمع قوي وكله
الان نرى
شكرا لك سيد ياسين